and in ukraine and and the domestic
policies and the approach over ukraine
and they are uh tackling uh the refugee
crisis is the government doing enough
criticism on all sides of the house that
that is just simply not the proper
processes in place
and the uk government isn't doing enough
to take refugees and then there's
something else that's bubbling up after
the prime minister along with uh the
president of the united states joe biden
and of course the european union
everyone announcing plans to reduce or
stop uh dependence on russian energy
supplies boris johnson's saying that the
uk will wind down its imports of russian
oil by the end of the year but there has
that does have a knock-on effect for
consumers and um i think there could be
questions from sarkir-stama today in the
commons about energy security
and the cost of living and as uh these
sanctions uh come into effect how might
that affect people at home just to give
you a bit of a taste on it the the
resolution foundation which is a think
tank which focuses on these issues this
week predicted the rise in global oil
and gas prices could push inflation to
above eight percent causing average
incomes to fall by four percent and that
could be a thousands of pounds a
household of cost of living crisis so
big questions about how this could
affect everyone at home so i wonder if
keir starman might go on that as well
and beth uh uh ireland have apparently
accepted two and a half thousand
refugees so far uh a pretty different uh
figure from uh britain's seven uh
england 760. yeah that's right um as of
yesterday ireland had taken
2123
ukrainian
refugees now that's because ireland is
part of the european union
and that block of countries has decided
to bring forward temporary protection
measures allowing ukrainians to enter
visa
free into their countries as refugees
and stay for up to three years now the
issue in the uk is that the government
don't want to do that pretty patel has
talked a lot the home secretary about
the need to screen people
coming in that has been deeply
controversial and popular with many of
their own mps and it's meant that people
are having to go through a lot of
paperwork and jump through a lot of
hoops to get a visa to enter the uk and
the government under pressure to change
that system and just to give you the
context of the difference between
ireland's approach and the uk the
population of the uk is 13 times larger
than ireland but so far we've offered
home to about a third as many refugees
okay the pm's up let's listen
mr speaker thank you never before has
this house listened to an address like
the one given yesterday by president
and so i want to tell the house that
working with our friends and allies
across the free world we will be doing
even more in the coming days to protect
the people of ukraine and mr speaker my
right honourable friend the defense
secretary will be setting out more
details for the house later on mr
speaker this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today probably let them thank you mr
speaker my son ben died from an aortic
dissection at age 44 leaving a wife and
two young children a condition which
kills 2 000 people every year needlessly
more than die on the roads
most people do not know anything about
this condition until it devastates their
family like mine
so many of these cases are preventable
by identifying those at risk and early
and accurate diagnosis would the prime
minister commend the work of the aortic
dissection charitable trust in working
with all aspects of the patient pathway
about this condition and in particular
will he commit to public funding for
research into the diagnosis of aortic
dissection and into genetic screening
for it
prime minister may i say to my
honourable friend first uh how very
sorry i am i'm sure the whole house is
for the loss of her son ben and she's a
passionate advocate for this work and i
thank the aortic dissection charitable
trust she's obviously mr speaker
completely right that accurate fast
diagnosis and treatment is crucial and
that's why i'm very pleased that the
national institute for health research
is looking to do uh further work in this
area and my right home will find the
secretary of state for health uh will
meet her at his earliest convenience no
come to the leader of the opposition kia
stammer
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker the typical energy
bill is going up by 700 pounds next
month
and that's because of pressures before
russia invaded ukraine
the chancellor's solution
a forced 200 pound loan for every
household paid back in mandatory
installments over five years
the big gamble behind that policy was
that energy costs
would drop quickly after a short spike
that bet now looks certain to fail
when will the prime minister force the
chancellor into a u-turn
uh mr speaker the uh myron from the
chancellor has set out plans to help
families with energy costs with
unprecedented measures to abate uh bait
council tax by uh by 150 pounds mr
speaker in addition uh to all the other
schemes uh that we are putting forward
and i can tell the house that uh yes
he's absolutely right uh that we need to
meet uh the long-term impacts of the
spike in uh in energy prices and that's
why i will be setting out an energy
independence plan uh for this country mr
speaker in the course
of the next few days uh to ensure that
we undo some of the damage of previous
decisions taken and not least by the
labor government to invest in uh not to
not to not to invest in nuclear uh mr
speaker and so and so that we
so that we prepare so that we prepare
our people uh for the long term and with
sustainable cost efficient energy supply
mr speaker i don't think the prime
minister understands the messy thing
working families are facing a 700 pound
spike in april
they won't even receive their 200 pound
loan from the chancellor until october
the wholesale price of oil and gas is
now ballooning so
by october when the loan finally comes
in household bills are set to shoot up
by another a thousand pounds
it's a total mess
so i ask again when is the prime
minister going to force the chancellor
to u-turn
prime minister
mr speaker he's asking for the
chancellor to you turn on the support
that we're giving to families and
households i i think that i think that
he's uh i think that he's absolutely out
of his mind uh we are we're we are going
to we are going to continue uh to give
people support throughout this difficult
period as we did throughout the
coronavirus epidemic mr speaker uh with
unprecedented levels of of support we
have a 200 pound discount on bills 150
pound a non-repayable a reduction in uh
council tax and 144 million pounds extra
to help council support vulnerable
families with their energy bills
all together mr speaker there is a 20
billion pound package of financial help
that we are giving the british people
and we will continue to do more i think
a u-turn this is because the last thing
we want
[Applause]
mr speaker we'll see how long that
position lasts
let me try and
let me try and help the prime minister
let me try and help the prime minister
by coming at it from a different angle
before russia invaded ukraine north sea
oil and gas companies were making bumper
profits
bp made 9.5 billion pounds
shell made 14 billion pounds
in their own words
more money than they know what to do
with
since then the international price of
oil and gas has skyrocketed and so will
their profits
when will the prime minister admit he's
got this badly wrong put a windfall tax
on those super profits and use the money
to cut household energy bills
[Applause]
mr speaker the the net result of that
would simply be to see the oil companies
uh put their prices up yet higher mr
speaker uh what we are what we are
and and and mr speaker
and mr speaker make it more difficult
for them to do what we need them to do
and which i think by the way mr speaker
they are doing very responsibly at the
moment and that is divesting from
dependence on russian oil and gas
and that is the that is the way forward
for this country it is to take it is to
take a sober responsible approach uh
end our dependence on on on hydrocarbons
all together and particularly russian
hydrocarbons and we are taking steps to
rectify some of the mistakes made by the
labor government and have a long-term
sustainable independent energy supply
policy that's what this country needs
[Applause]
protecting energy profits not working
people doesn't that say it all
britain
[Applause]
britain can't
britain can't afford another crisis like
this we need to improve our long-term
energy security that starts that starts
with supporting new nuclear and
renewables
but the conservatives have effectively
banned new onshore wind
as a direct result of this short-sighted
approach we're using more gas every year
than we import from russia
that's ludicrous
so will the prime minister relax
planning laws end the block on onshore
wind and stop supporting policies that
make us so dependent on foreign gas
prime minister speaker it's thanks to
the it's thanks to the policies that
this government has pursued uh that we
actually only are dependent on a russian
gas for three percent of our gas needs
unlike unlike virtually every other
european country mr speaker it's thanks
to the massive investment that we've had
in renewables mr speaker uh that we are
the as i've said many times in this
house the saudi arabia of wind power
produced a more offshore wind uh than
virtually any other country in the world
mr speaker and i'm i think he just by
the way i think he just committed to
supporting this may be news to some of
his party but he just committed to
supporting more nuclear power
there is more
there is more joy in heaven mr speaker
there there's more joy in heaven over
one sinner that repented mr speaker than
over a hundred i i'm delight and did
that those were the people mr speaker
who cancelled our nuclear efforts
in the time they were in power they did
completely the wrong thing i'm delighted
to welcome them now into the farm
and come off it
laborious pro-nuclear
this prime minister can't get a single
bricklayed of a new nuclear plant
[Applause]
energy security isn't just about supply
it's also about reducing demand
our housing stock is the least efficient
in europe that's why labour set out a
plan to upgrade the 19 million british
homes that desperately need it within a
decade
saving families 400 pounds on their
energy bill and cutting uk gas imports
by 15
whereas all the government have is a
failed policy taking all their
announcements together it will take 75
years to deliver the upgrades that we
need that's a lifetime when we need
urgent action when is the prime minister
going to get on with it
prime minister well mr speaker i just i
just remind the house that under the uh
the labour government our nuclear output
fell from i think about 25 percent uh to
about 10 percent of our of our energy
[Applause]
it was because of the decisions that
they took we're now going to rectify mr
speaker and we're helping households but
he asked about the cost of energy bills
we're helping households with the cost
of energy bills to the tune of 9.1
billion pounds now why can this
government afford to do that why can we
afford to put huge quantities of
taxpayers money into supporting
households and their energy costs i'll
tell you why mr speaker it's because we
got the fastest growth in the g7
and
and don't forget that if we listen to
captain hindsight and we'd have stayed
in lockdown and we'd have never achieved
it mr speaker
12 years in pam that's the best he can
do
the ukrainian people
the ukrainian people
[Applause]
mr speaker the ukrainian people are
fighting for democracy we must stand
with them that means taking the toughest
possible measures against putin
and let's be honest there'll be costs
here at home
we can withstand those costs and we must
by using a windfall tax to keep bills
down for working people
by starting a new era of energy policy
never again at the mercy of a dictator
supporting new nuclear after years of
neglect
sprinting on renewables including
onshore wind
and an urgent national mission to
upgrade homes and in years of dither and
delay
so why is the prime minister offering
the same failed energy policy that cast
us into the security crisis and allowed
bills to rock it
mr speaker what we are what we are
sorry prime minister i won't tell you
the answer but also standing up's not
going to catch my eye in fact it's got
the opposite effect on me prime minister
mr speaker what we are junking is the
failed energy policies that left us
without enough nuclear power mr speaker
and what we are going to do is go
forward with policies that allow this
country to be independent in our energy
supply and maximizing renewables mr
speaker
making sure that we use transitional
hydrocarbons and going for nuclear as
well as i say i'm overjoyed that labor
now seems to occupy uh that position but
what we will also do mr speaker
and and here he has been supportive is
make sure that as a house of commons we
work together to maintain our opposition
to vladimir putin's vile war in uh in
ukraine and there together with the
toughest possible economic sanctions by
maintaining our military support for the
people of ukraine i have no doubt that
though he's though there will be dark
days ahead and difficult times mr
speaker we will come through it stronger
and i have no doubt that vladimir putin
will fail and we will succeed in
restoring a sovereign and independent
ukraine
thank you thank you mr speaker for over
two decades thames water has been trying
to build a reservoir in my constituency
that would be over 30 meters high and
cover the equivalent of over 2 500
football pitches this has been a shadow
over the local community who don't think
they've proven the need for this
proposal does my right honourable friend
agree that if a company seeks to do
something like this it has to show why
it's needed why it's better than the
alternatives and what the environmental
impact will be they can't behave as
though it's inevitable whether the local
community want it or not prime minister
well mr speaker i thank my honorable
friend he's a fantastic champion for his
uh his constituents in in wantage that
as i understand it the decision on the
abingdon reservoir has not actually uh
been made but we would expect thames
water to consult further on the uh
proposal and i know that they will have
heard the points that my honourable
friend has rightly made we now come to
smp leader in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker we are now 14 days
into putin's war and in that time i've
generally tried to work constructively
with the uk government i will continue
to seek to do this however
nobody should support this government
when it comes to the response to the
refugee crisis
760 visa approvals in two weeks is
disgraceful in that time poland has
taken over 1.2 million refugees hungary
has taken over 190 000 refugees germany
has taken over fifty thousand use italy
over seven thousand refugees ireland
a country of just over five million
people has given sanctuary to three
times as many refugees as the united
kingdom these numbers don't lie
they tell a devastating truth
does the prime minister find it
acceptable that his home secretary has
overseen one of the slowest most
bureaucratic and incompetent refugee
responses in the whole of europe
[Music]
mr speaker i think everybody sympathizes
with the plight of of refugees and and
uh this government wants to do
everything we can to to welcome them and
and that is indeed what we are doing and
the numbers are uh almost a thousand as
i speak to uh to him today and they will
rise very sharply mr speaker uh the they
are uncapped we expect those numbers to
rise uh to uh in the region of the
hundreds of thousands uh as as the uh as
vladimir putin doubles down in his
attacks we will go further mr speaker
and there will be uh routes by which the
whole country can offer uh uh offer a
welcome uh to people from uh ukraine
vulnerable people fleeing uh from
ukraine and my right honorable friend
the secretary of state uh for uh for
leveling up will be setting out that
route in the course of the next few days
this government has a proud proud record
we've done more to resettle vulnerable
people than any other european country
since 2015.
in blackfoot
i don't think the prime minister
understands the scale of the challenge
or the other urgency these are people
fleeing war crimes torn apart from their
families as their homes are failed and
the home secretary is blocking them with
endless paperwork this isn't just
incompetence this is ideology in the
face of the biggest refugee crisis in
europe since the second world war the uk
government won't set aside the hostile
environment and by the way we're seeing
the hostile environment this afternoon
they might point down a bit
we've seen this too many times from a
tory home office the windrush scandal
the go home vans the inhumane
nationality and borders bill the uk home
office is raising barriers and
bureaucracy when we should be offering
care and compassion prime minister do
not let the history of failure repeat
itself scotland stands ready to offer
sanctuary and refuge so will the prime
minister
join with the rest of the european
continent and waive the visa
restrictions for refugees fleeing war in
ukraine
mr speaker this country has an
unparalleled record
just just since i have been prime
minister
look at what the numbers we've taken
from afghanistan uh from hong kong mr
speaker he lectures the home secretary
this is a government unlike any other
the prime minister the deputy prime
minister the home secretary are directly
descended mr speaker from refugees
and we understand we understand how much
refugees have to give to this country
and we understand how much this country
has to gain from welcoming refugees and
we will be generous and we are being
generous mr speaker and what we are
doing is making sure that in those in
those neighboring countries the uk is
out in front giving the humanitarian
assistance
and we are in every capital mr speaker
they laugh mr speaker they mock they
scoff this country and is leading in
every respect but we are also the single
biggest donor of humanitarian aid
to the ukraine war zone mr speaker the
single biggest don't know he should be
proud of that
julian smith thank you mr speaker i
commend the prime minister's uh response
to this ukrainian crisis but i think
people across the country are genuinely
concerned on our response on refugees on
the bureaucracy
on the tone of our response he's shown
with vaccines
that government change really comes from
the very top
please can i urge him to look again on
resetting our policy and taking control
of a more humane approach to those women
and men fleeing from ukraine
thank you very much he will have i hope
i thank you very much i thank you for
all the the work that he does in this
area but i hope you will have heard uh
what i've i've just said in my uh my
earlier answer to the leader of the snp
which is mr speaker that uh this
government is i think unlike any other
in our understanding of what uh refugees
can give and the benefits to this
country and we want uh we've done more
than any other to resettle vulnerable
people since since 2015. i think that
there is a huge opportunity now uh for
us to do even more and that's why my
writer will find the secretary of state
for leveling up we'll be setting out a
route by which the british people uh not
just the family reunion route which can
run into the hundreds of thousands mr
speaker but also a route by which uh
everybody in this country can offer a
home to people fleeing ukraine and uh
my vulnerable friend will be setting
that out in the course of the next few
days so jeffrey donaldson thank you mr
speaker the prime minister will be
acutely aware of the pressures facing
high schools across the united kingdom
including in northern ireland with the
rapid increase in the cost of heating
homes and running a motor vehicle
heating
a home has increased has more than
doubled for many households in northern
ireland in recent weeks will the prime
minister commit to bring forward a uh
package of measures designed to help
households including a cut in vat on
home heating fuel
reducing or cutting excise duty on fuel
for motorists and will he ensure that
those measures apply to northern ireland
where the northern ireland protocol once
again presents a problem in this
government taking control over the
affairs of all of the united kingdom
will the decisions that the treasury
take apply to the whole of the united
kingdom
prime minister mr speaker we will make
sure that we do everything uh to support
the people of the whole of the united
kingdom including uh northern ireland
and we've already uh extended a further
250 million to help the people of
northern uh with the costs of uh living
particularly uh heating as he knows
excises uh on fuel is uh has been frozen
for the last uh for the last 12 years
and we will ensure that the people of
northern ireland continue to be
protected along with everybody in the uk
uh from uh the cost of of living crisis
but there should have should be in in no
doubt that the pressures on on energy
will uh continue uh we need a pan uh uk
solution and that's what we're going to
be setting out i'm stevenson thank you
mr speaker prime minister the world has
changed energy security is vital but so
too is food security our food and drink
manufacturers and those in the food
chain prove their worth during the
pandemic
given the importance to our country of
this sector and the need to ensure its
competitiveness is resilience and a high
degree of self-sufficiency will the
prime minister now take the opportunity
to review many of the proposed
regulatory burdens such as hfss and the
promotional and marketing restrictions
which could adversely affect this
important sector at this critical time
prime minister uh
mr speaker he's he's absolutely right
that
food security is a a crucial issue and
it is affected of course by the cost of
energy and the the energy inputs into
agriculture uh are certainly something
that we need to uh to address there is
also a separate issue mr speaker to do
with childhood uh obesity the house uh
past uh measures uh already uh in the
autumn uh the ones to which he uh refers
we're giving uh the industry more time
to adjust uh to the uh the impact of
those measures greg morris
thank you mr speaker
prime minister in addition to the
increase
in fuel prices our constituents are
reporting to us that the energy
companies are doubling standing charges
in france energy supply company edf has
had energy price rises to domestic
customers capped at four percent
but this government price cut allows edf
to increase prices to uk customers by 54
percent my question is why
[Music]
this is because we have no we have an
overall cap and obviously the the uh the
the edf is incorporated differently in
the uk from its incorporation in france
but we will do everything uh in our
power to abate the costs of energy
across the country as we already are uh
mr speaker uh but what it needs is a uh
a short-term medium and long-term energy
strategy so that we have sustainable uh
supplies
thank you very much indeed mr speaker
soon after i was elected i found out
that shotley bridge an eight-bedroom
community
bed community hospital in my
constituency is replaced with a zero bed
unit something labor councillors some
labor councils had known about and said
nothing about during the election
campaign after campaigning
with ministers and their secretary of
state and working with my local nhs
trust a new 16-bed unit is now in the
final stages of planning and has been
confirmed as part of this government's
hospital building program can the prime
minister confirm that this new community
hospital is now full steam ahead and
will he commit to coming to concert to
kick off the building works if the plan
goes to head uh by the end of next year
yes yes mr speaker i'm delighted
there'll be a new hospital at shotley
bridge i congratulate him all the work
he's done to to lobby for it and mr
speaker what it proves that this
government is getting on in spite of the
pandemic in spite of war in ukraine this
government is getting on with the job
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mr deputy speaker i've just
been to a very harrowing meeting with
families affected
they have members of families in care
homes and hospitals
and they've
suffered unjustifiable
denial of access to those loved ones
and have been massively restricted
and it continues despite the postcode
environment would the prime minister be
prepared to introduce legislation to
make access to loved ones in care homes
and hospitals a legal right and not at
the discretion of the care home or the
hospital concern
mr speaker i thank him very much and i
think everybody understands the uh the
the anguish of people who haven't been
able to see their loved ones uh during
the pandemic we have uh relaxed the
restrictions in care homes as uh as he
knows uh if i'd be very happy to offer a
meeting for him and the relevant uh
health minister to discuss uh his
further concerns john penrose uh mr
speaker the government's already stopped
issuing golden visas so they can't be
exploited by oligarchs and crime lords
but some could already be here living in
luxury london penthouse flats they've
bought with dirty cash
so will the prime minister pledge that
anybody
will he pledge that anybody who's put on
the sanctions list in the coming days
and is already in the uk on a golden
visa will have it ripped up so they can
be thrown out
prime minister uh
yes sir mr speaker i can tell him that
and i i i thank the house for what we've
done to uh accelerate the uh the
economic crime measures because we will
be able to whip aside the veil of
anonymity uh mr speaker the ownership of
these uh
luxurious dwellings to which he refers
will be exposed and yes we will be able
to take away their ability to remain in
this country barbara keeley yeah yeah
yeah thank you mr speaker as energy
costs spiral i want to raise the issue
for people who use extra electricity to
charge their electric wheelchairs or to
run ventilators or a stair lift
it is not right that people with a
disability or a serious medical
condition should face unmanageable debt
or going without food to pay the cost of
electricity on which they absolutely
rely
they need a real cut to their bills
right now so why isn't the prime
minister looking at drawing on the
profits of the north sea oil and gas
companies to help the most vulnerable
families with those costs
i thank you very much she raises a very
important issue and
clearly the the spike in energy prices
is going to fall uh most heavily on uh
vulnerable people such as the ones that
uh she's mentioned and we will certainly
be looking at ways uh to abate their
costs
[Applause]
i don't know what i've done to deserve
that um
residents in the village of hamburg in
my constituency are currently facing the
prospect of a quarry being given
planning permission with 144 lorries per
day in this congested area with one road
access will my right honourable friend
agree to meet with me to discuss how we
can tighten the regulations and where
quarries can be built to take into
account the health implication our
environment and our local communities
[Applause]
i thank my honourable friend and he's a
great champion for for eastleigh uh the
planning framework is is robust and uh
should ensure that quarries don't have
an adverse impact on the uh on the
environment or on health but i'll make
sure that he gets a meeting with the
relevant minister to discuss his
concerns further
ponderosa
[Applause]
mr speaker we have seen in recent weeks
how serious and dangerous russia's covet
influence in britain can be yeah we have
seen that putin actively seeks to
influence the culture media
and politics of democratic nations
our national security is of the greatest
importance and britain cannot become
home to those that prop up putin and his
war
with that in mind has the prime minister
ever overruled security service advice
when a point and appear to the other
place
[Applause]
uh no mr speaker and uh actually the
kremlin has singled out the uk for being
in the lead uh on the on global
sanctions
and in
as they have and and and mr speaker in
leading the world in defiance of the
odious war that putin is leading in
ukraine
greg clark
yesterday president zielinski drew on
the words of churchill in this chamber
and as we salute the courage of the
people of ukraine it reminds us that we
can meet in freedom today only because
of the courage of a generation of men
and women who in the second world war
defended us from annihilation
among them is my friend flight
lieutenant colin bell dfc who flew his
de havilland mosquito in 50 missions
over nazi germany
colin bell is with us today
on saturday
he celebrated his 101st birthday
will the prime minister join me in
wishing colleen a very happy birthday
and thanking him for what he did for
allowing us to be here today
mr speaker i think the whole house will
want to uh join me in uh thanking him
and thank you and wishing colin bell a
very happy 101st birthday
brendan
o'hara thank you mr speaker people
across these islands have displayed
remarkable generosity including an
agaylan buke where oban helps ukraine
have been overwhelmed by donations of
money of clothes and of offers of
shelter sadly this government's
reluctance to allow fleeing women and
children to come here lags far behind
the desire of the people here to provide
them with a roof and a bed
doesn't the prime minister fear that
when this war is concluded and despite
whatever else it may have done
that his government will stand accused
of lacking the one thing the ukrainian
people needed most
basic
yeah humanity minister
mr speaker i really don't think that
that uh question reflects the uh the
views of people around the world and nor
does it mr speaker does it reflect nor
does it reflect reality because this
government has done more than any other
european country uh to support people in
uh by way of direct bilateral
humanitarian aid mr speaker
and we have we have two very generous
schemes for allowing people to come to
this country this is a government that
believes in welcoming people uh fleeing
from zones of conflict and mr speaker if
he shakes his head look at our record
look at what we've done just look at
what we've done just in the last two
years and he should be proud he should
be proud of what we've done you may not
thank you mr speaker we were pleased to
welcome both the prime minister and the
secretary secretary blackpool the day
after the launch of the doubling up
white paper will he meet with me to
discuss how we can make sure that
blackpool is not just a testbed for
innovation in many of the areas of
opening up but to showcase for the
impact it can have on the community that
i represent yeah
i thank him for his wonderful work in uh
in blackball for communities he he
represents and i was it was fantastic to
be uh to be with him and to see the the
increase the the extension and the
upgrading of the tram network uh in
blackpool mr speaker that will help to
drive the economy and help to bring
high-wage high-skilled jobs in just the
way that we hope to do that across the
whole of the uk as we get on with
levelling up
david
speaker in the months before world war
ii
the uk took in over 60 000 jewish
refugees fleeing nazi persecution
over half a century ago we took in over
27 000 ugandans expelled by idi armin
since then we've taken tamil's escaping
civil war
bosnians escaping genocide
and syrians escaping assad
but this week
the home office turned away hundreds of
ukrainian refugees escaping putin's
bombs because they didn't have the right
paperwork
can the prime minister not see
that this flies in the face of our
country's proud tradition of providing
sanctuary
and since the home office clearly isn't
up to the task
will the prime minister send in armed
forces personnel
to speed up the process so ukrainian
refugees can come here quickly and
safely
prime minister mr speaker i i thank him
very much and the whole house wants to
do as much as we can and as fast as
possible but what he says about about
the uk is i'm afraid uh completely wrong
um mr speaker because uh we have visa
centers open in warsaw and budapest in
prague and yeshua in in poland in in
chisholm in moldova uh bucharest and and
elsewhere mr speaker uh we've already uh
got more than we've already got a
thousand people in under the existing
scene that number will climb uh very
sharply mr speaker look at what we've
done already uh fifteen thousand fifteen
thousand from afghanistan hundred and
four thousand applications uh from uh
from hong kong uh chinese and i think
there were about 25 000 uh from syria no
one has been turned away mr speaker that
is that is simply we want we want to be
as generous and well mr speaker it is
important to have checks let me make
this point to the house because i do
think it's i think people need to
understand there are some people there
are some people mr speaker who would i
like to dispense with checks altogether
and simply to wave people through and
i've got to say
and i hear these and i hear the voices
on the bench is opposite i i think that
is i do think that that is irresponsible
and and that is not the approach that we
should be taking the schengen countries
have a different arrangement we must be
in no doubt as i said in answer to a
previous question the kremlin has
singled out this country for the
approach that we are taking vladimir
putin and we know how unscrupulous putin
can be in his methods it would not be
right mr speaker to expose this country
to our necessary security risk and we
will not do it mr speaker we are going
to be as generous as we can possibly be
but we must have checks barely
mr speaker
my community in tipton came together on
sunday to commemorate 100 years since
the devastating explosion of the dudley
port munitions factory and the 19 girls
who are recklessly murdered by the owner
of that factory now in the black country
it's vital that we acknowledge both the
pride but also the pain of our
industrial heritage and can i ask my
right honourable friend therefore to
ensure that to reaffirm his commitment
today to the black country to ensure
that we honor that legacy of those girls
in that factory in dudley port 100 years
ago and the one way that my rightful
friend can do that for my community in
tipton is to come to tipton mr speaker
and see that beating heart of the black
country who are welcoming with open arms
well mr speaker long long ago
when i was a reporter tipton was on my
beat
many years ago and i would wild horses
wouldn't keep me away from tipton i'll
be back
rodney cohen's final question
thank you mr speaker
prime minister i have a constituent
whose elderly parents are seeking refuge
in the united kingdom from ukraine her
parents are both in their 80s they've
made it to hungary they went to the visa
application center as instructed by the
home office hotline and they were told
come back on the 22nd of march
then and only then will their biometrics
be processed
that is a harsh reality no spin no
subdivision
prime minister when will refugees when
will refugees from the ukraine be
welcomed into the united kingdom
i thank you if you'd be kind enough i'd
be grateful if you'd pass me the details
of the case uh that he mentions and i'd
be happy to uh to to give it to my uh to
my right honourable friend we are we are
moving heaven and earth mr speaker
because we we understand we understand
the value uh to this country of refugees
we also understand the imperative of
helping people fleeing a war zone in
terror and that's why the people of this
country want to open their arms and we
are going to help them to do it mr
speaker with a new humanitarian route in
addition to the family reunion route
that we have already set up that that
family reunion route alone mr speaker
could bring hundreds of thousands of
people here and i think the whole house
understands that we will do even more
through the new humanitarian route
that's the end of prime minister's
questions please leave quietly
all right john
and that is the end of prime minister's
questions for this week we are expecting
though defense secretary ben wallace to
give the house uh an update at some time
as soon as that happened for that update
on ukraine we will take you back to
the house of commons in the meantime i'm
joined by uh political editor beth rigby
um beth a two-pronged approach there to
pmq's uh kierstama picking up the cost
of living okay we're going to go to that
statement from defense thank you mr
speaker with permission i would like to
update the house on the situation in
ukraine
and hmg supports the government in kiev
mr speaker the situation on the ground
is grave
as we can recall on the 24th of february
forces of the russian army
unprovoked crossed into ukraine
sovereign territory
along three main axises russian armour
has attempted to occupy ukraine
their plan was to reach and encircle
kiev encircle ukrainian forces near the
border and invade from the south to link
up with their forces via mario pole
russian high command had committed 65
of their entire land forces and
indisputably are in possession of
overwhelming firepower and armor
it is estimated that at the start of
this invasion they had between 110 and